can you speak to what a dwarf Galaxy is
can you speak to what this particular
two dwarf Galaxy is that it's orbiting
the Milky Way galaxy yeah it's going to
be eaten by it presumably it totally is
going to be eaten I can't tell you
exactly when
um yeah the Milky Way remains surrounded
by dozens of small dwarf galaxies and
they are collections of stars
um some of them uh we call them Ultra
fiend dwarf galaxies because they now
only contain I don't know a few thousand
stars very very faint still detectable
uh yes because they're fairly close and
and we detect actual individual stars in
them so I've observed some of the the
faintest Stars you know you possibly
observed with current telescopes in in
these dwarf galaxies because I was like
I need to know what the chemical
composition is because there are
leftovers from the early Universe right
they they did not get eaten so they are
still in their native surroundings I I
go it's like getting the lions in the
wild right I gotta study those and
compare to the counterparts that got
eaten and are now in the Milky Way and
so I so presumably most of those Stars
it's not all those Stars Network Galaxy
are really ancient they all really
ancient because actually as it turns out
if you have a small Galaxy
um
there was a process early on in the
universe called reionization that kind
of heated up everything and together
with some Supernova explosions in an
early shallow you know bound system
all these little systems lost the gas it
was sort of blown out or it simply
evaporated or both probably both
um and so these systems have been unable
to continue to form Stars since so it's
it's it's the best
for a Stella archaeologists that you
could hope for because it's a whole
bunch of stars still sitting there it's
not just one it's a whole bunch of them
still sitting there ever since and
nothing has literally nothing has
happened to them they're just been
waiting there for us so from the Stellar
archeology perspective what is like
juicier more interesting the uh
the All-Stars and the outskirts that
have been eaten are the Oscar's Milky
Way or the the the stars in the in the
dwarf galaxies what's what's uh about
the world you said you love Stars so uh
which do you love more of you oh that's
a hard one I mean I love them all of
course
um they serve different purposes the the
SAS in the Milky Way um I can get much
much better data for them because
they're brighter they're closer so
they're brighter and that that tickles
my fancy and they have interesting
kinematics presumably yes and we can get
that and so he1523 for example you know
that one is really bright only it's a
red giant so it's intrinsically bright
and it's fairly close
and so the data I got for that was
insanely good and that yielded this
uranium detection and thorium detection
um I can never get that kind of data for
dwarf Galaxy Star so that's a big
trade-off but the environmental
information that would we get along with
the basic information about these stars
in each dwarf Galaxy is really really
valuable in establishing you know these
for example these site information right
sure because the the Galaxy is still
there so nothing crazy could have
happened so actually to close that Loop
probably some heavy elements come out of
supernovae here and there but somehow my
theory colleagues tell me that the
normal Supernova just doesn't have
enough oomph to really get an R process
going and doing doing it all so
desorbiting super
we need them the probably the neutron
star mergers or we need a special kind
of supernova that's maybe extremely
massive or heavily rotating or does
something else funny right to really
kind of get that particular process
going but uh the normal supernovae don't
do it right so only a little bit comes
out but you could come alongside Anna
why don't you just take a hundred
supernovae together to build up the
yield right but then I come along and
say like Mike look this dwarf Galaxy is
still intact today if you would have
plugged in 100 supernovae into this
little system early on it would have
blown apart it would have blown apart
past five supernovia or ten so that's a
really important constraint that we have
that these systems are still alive right
so
um it helps us to pin down where certain
processes could have possibly happened
and so that's it's just a it's just a
different type of information that we
get